what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and it looks like we
have our villain for the Thunderbolts
and it is the one and only Century who
many people right now are referring to
as evil Superman now I don't entirely
agree with this Sentry after all is a
superhero albeit a very complicated
superhero who could very well indeed be
a villain But ultimately be a superhero
in the MCU kind of like what they're
doing with Namor right now obviously
Namor was the villain in Black Panther
wakanda forever he did some very
villainous things I won't put any
spoilers out there but he was pretty
ruthless however we know that name or
many many times in the comics has helped
out a lot of the superhero teams and was
even a part of the Illuminati I'm
assuming that the same thing is kind of
going to happen for Century which of
course we're going to be talking about
in this video as well as going over some
of the plot details that we have
recently found out about the thunder
movie now if you were excited for the
Thunderbolts this should get you even
more excited and if you were kind of on
the fence hopefully this will change
your mind and make you excited about the
film also we'll be doing a lot of really
cool holiday giveaways soon so be sure
to subscribe to the channel and hit that
notification Bell so you don't miss out
now what's really interesting about
Sentry entering the MCU is that we could
have two possible actors to play him
already and I gotta say I actually
really like the casting choices so far
but let's go ahead and first start off
with the recent reports one is coming
from Daniel rbk it says rumor the
Thunderbolts will surely have a lot on
their plate as the adversary in their
film is going to be Robert Reynolds aka
the Sentry now adversary is in quotes
and I believe the reason it's in quotes
is because Century really isn't a True
Villain there is some evil that comes
with him in more than one way which I'll
talk about in this video but overall
century is a hero a lot of people look
up to him including Spider-Man he
becomes a role model for Spider-Man and
he becomes really good friends with
people like Reed Richards the Fantastic
Four as a whole The Avengers and some
X-Men as well now this report is from
Daniel rpk's patreon account but even
before this came out Grace Randolph
tweeted saying sounds like Marvel is
casting an evil Superman for
Thunderbolts it's gonna be hard to top
homelander and even Grace put evil
Superman in quotes as well and I do
believe I know kind of what the story is
going to be with century and why he is
going to be evil but first let's talk
about the second part of Grace's tweet
where she says Gosling and Skarsgard
might be potential casting choices now
at this point in time we're pretty sure
Ryan Gosling has had a few different
meetings with Marvel Studios it's been
rumored that he could be playing Nova
but really what's going on is he's met
with Marvel Studios about several
different projects in Marvel Studios and
Kevin feige are confirmed to do this
with many many different actors Kevin
feige meets with many different actors
over long periods of time sometimes to
see if they are right for a specific
role Jake Gyllenhaal is the perfect
example Marvel Studios met with him many
times over many different years they
didn't just meet with him and say hey
you should play Mysterio he met with
them years before and finally the
Mysterio role came out and they said hey
this would be a perfect fit for you what
do you think and he said yes so the same
thing is most likely happening with Ryan
Gosling he's been meeting with Marvel
Studios about many different roles and
perhaps a current role right now could
be Century now Alexander Skarsgard I
think would make a really good Sentry as
well and if anybody has seen Tarzan or
has simply seen what he looked like in
Tarzan the way he got in shape and the
way he buffed up you can see that he
would make a pretty dang good Sentry he
even has the long blonde hair in that
movie so I honestly think that either of
these two actors would make a pretty
dang good Sentry and I like both of them
for this choice I think each would bring
something different to the table but
each would do a really good job and both
of them are able to bulk up and be
really really big for the role because
like everybody is calling him he is
essentially Marvel Superman so naturally
and kind of unfortunately I think people
are going to compare Century to Henry
Cavill Superman so whoever plays role is
gonna have to get jacked now as far as
Sentry being the villain in the
Thunderbolts film I think I pretty much
know how this is going to work now first
things first you have to know that it is
confirmed that Harrison Ford is going to
be replacing William Hurt as Thunderbolt
Ross sadly William Hurt passed away but
Marvel Studios had some pretty big plans
for his character Thunderbolt Ross so
they have decided to recast and Harrison
Ford is confirmed it has also been
reported that Thunderbolt Ross is going
to be the president in the Thunderbolts
movie the president of the United States
and on top of that it is confirmed that
we are going to see him turn into Red
Hulk in the movie actually what is kind
of interesting is all of this is
confirmed for Captain America 4 New
World Order which will come out only
months before the Thunderbolts film so
so Captain America 4 is going to set up
a lot of events of the Thunderbolts
specifically concerning the super
soldier serum which has a direct
involvement with Sentry as well now
Robert Reynolds AKA Sentry was a meth
addict he was a meth head and one day he
broke into a laboratory where he
discovered the golden Century serum and
he consumed it now the golden Century
serum was essentially the super soldier
serum but magnified by about a hundred
thousand so think about how strong
Captain America was and magnify that by
a ton now what had happened was was in
1947 Canada's Department K and the
United States operation rebirth pulled
their resources to become project Sentry
and attempted to recreate the super
soldier serum but not just recreate it
but magnify its effects by one hundred
thousand unfortunately 30 years into
this this project had turned into about
a thousand different subunits and they
didn't really have any type of system in
place to monitor all of these subunits
so basically every unit was kind of just
doing whatever they felt like with no
real regulation whatsoever so you have
all of these sub units trying to
recreate the super soldier serum except
a hundred times more powerful so Robert
Reynolds breaks into one of the labs and
consumes the golden Century serum giving
him the power of a million exploding
Suns when he consumed this he killed his
partner and all of the lab's guards but
obviously he loved the effect and he
asked the professor to make him more
however the project leaders discovered
what happened and they were appalled
appalled at what had happened but also
appalled that they didn't really have
any system in place to make sure that
stuff like this didn't happen so they
asked Robert Reynolds if they could do
tests on him in which he agreed but soon
they couldn't really control him as his
desire to do good by his powers was too
much so he finally left he sewed himself
a costume and called himself Sentry and
from there on century was a hero like I
said he became friends with a lot of
different superheroes and Spider-Man
even looked up to him after Century
discovered his identity was Peter Parker
but unfortunately What followed is what
I think is going to possibly show up in
the Thunderbolts a being called the void
arrived which was a shadowy monster
which essentially used a person's own
greatest fears against them and it
murdered over one million people in
Manhattan however it was discovered that
the void was the own dark aspect of
Sentry's own powers so the only way to
beat the void was to team up with Reed
Richards and Doctor Strange to create a
system which made Earth's entire
population forget that Century ever
existed sounds kind of familiar doesn't
it Doctor Strange was even involved in
that as well making everybody forget
that Peter Parker existed in that he was
Spider-Man but in the story when
everybody forgot that century and Robert
Reynolds existed the void vanished the
void was powered by the Century's Powers
but here's where things get really
interesting eventually Robert Reynolds
was captured and he was brought to the
mutant Illusionist Mastermind and he
implanted a mental virus inside of
Century's mind basically telling him and
convincing him that if he used his
powers a devil would appear this
prevented him from using his powers so
I'm assuming something like this is
going to happen in the Thunderbolts
Robert Reynolds will most likely be the
subject of some super soldier experiment
with an amplified super soldier serum it
will most likely be successful for him
turning him into Century however the
government is probably going to implant
something inside of his head that
basically makes him work for them
however he might get too much out of
control or an actual villain might take
control over him and that is why he is
going to be a villain however he is
going to be the product of some United
States experiment so the United States
has to take care of it so it doesn't get
out so that is why they send the
Thunderbolts team because it's kind of a
sketchy experiment and you probably
don't want people to know about it so
you send the Thunderbolts team the group
of villains and we all know Thunderbolt
Ross has been searching for super
soldier serum and most likely
experimenting on it for a while so this
is most likely a byproduct of his
experiment so that is why he is going to
be involved as well and how we'll most
likely see Red Hulk but I'm assuming by
the end of the Thunderbolts film or
maybe even in the post-credits scene for
it we will see Century become good be
released from whatever mental prison
he's being put under whether that's a
mental microchip or an illusion or
hypnosis that will be released and
Century should be a hero in the MCU and
I'm really excited for it but hey let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below and does this make
you excited for the Thunderbolts let me
know down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof